looking for blessings just ahead of the
presidential election in Singapore's
full Hai Chan monastery presidential
candidate
talks to the Abbot about racial Harmony
and religious tolerance a key message in
this culturally diverse city-state
but Mr NG is less Keen to discuss the
election race children bring such
political talk into a holy place
this is the temple
this is a monastery you know
the man many assume to be the front
runner is a former deputy prime minister
from the ruling people's action party or
the pap
although the presidency is a largely
ceremonial role previous incumbents had
strong links to the pap
it will be a more difficult and
challenging future that we face which is
the reason why I have entered this
contest
to offer all my experience and
capabilities
but the pap has faced several corruption
investigations and questions over the
immoral behavior of its MPS this year
the party appears more vulnerable than
it has in a long time
for most singaporeans it's a struggle to
stay afloat in one of the richest
countries in the world daily expenses
and rent have risen dramatically in
recent years a real pressure
particularly on the young
political podcasters Terence Char and
haresh talani point out that this is the
first election many of their listeners
will have voted in and for Singapore's
youth promises a political stability
aren't always enough doesn't things
stand out housing cost of living and
because while we can hear the plans of
what is going to happen the feeling in
the the current state is is different
people are feeling stressed people are
feeling squeezed elections here are
usually very predictable things the
ruling parties been in power since 1959
but with a new generation of Voters
going to The Ballot Box there is the
possibility this presidential election
could see that very rare thing
a protest vote Tony Chang altazira
Singapore
make sure to subscribe to our channel to
get the latest news from Al Jazeera